IS A GOOD MUSICAL >> Greg:
AFTER TRASHING DONALD TRUMP FOR
HIS EVIL AMERICA-FIRST DANCE,
JOE BIDEN ASSEMBLED HIS BRAIN
TRUST AND CAME UP WITH SOMETHING
FAR BETTER.
AMERICA FIRST.
"I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
GOING TO FIGHT BY INVESTING IN
AMERICA FIRST.
I’M NOT GOING TO ENTER ANY NEW
TRADE AGREEMENTS WITH ANYBODY
UNTIL WE HAVE MADE MAJOR
INVESTMENTS HERE AT HOME AND IN
OUR WORKERS.
WELL, YOU KNOW, I’M OLD ENOUGH
TO REMEMBER WHEN JOE FELT
DIFFERENTLY.
>> AMERICA FIRST HAS MADE
AMERICA ALONE UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, OUR ALLIANCES
ARE IN JEOPARDY, WE ARE MORE
ISOLATED IN THE WORLD THAN WE’VE
EVER BEEN AND OUR ALLIES,
AMERICA FIRST HAS MADE AMERICA
ALONE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS CHANGED THE
LANDSCAPE, IT’S BECOME AMERICA
FIRST WHICH IS BEEN AMERICA
ALONE.
>> Greg: I ALSO REMEMBER THE
DAY AFTER THE TRAVEL BAN WHEN
BIDEN TWEETED THIS.
"WE NEED TO LEAD THE WAY WITH
SCIENCE, NOT DONALD TRUMP’S
RECORD OF XENOPHOBIA AND
FEARMONGERING.
THEN WHAT DOES HE DO?
FAX THE TRAVEL BAN THREE MONTHS
LATE.
IF TRUMP DID IT IT’S EVIL, UNTIL
JOE SLOWLY REALIZES IT’S NOT AND
THEN STEALS IT.
HE WILL TAKE THE TRAVEL BAN, THE
PRO-FRACKING POLICY, THE
VACCINES, THOSE TARIFFS ON CHINA
AND JOE IS PREACHING UNITY NOW,
A TRUMP RALLYING CRY AFTER JOE
HIMSELF BRANDED HALF OF AMERICA
RACIST AND NOW IT’S AMERICA
FIRST.
JOE SUFFERS FROM THE HATE TRUMP
BUT LOVE HIS IDEAS DISORDER.
JOE WILL SEE WHAT TRUMP HAS DONE
AND THINK, I CAN’T DO BETTER AND
HE’S RIGHT SO JOE’S FIRST TERM
MIGHT IN FACT BE TRUMP’S S SECON
AT ANYTHING THE PRESS CONDEMNED
THE ORANGE GODZILLA FOUR WILL
BECOME AWESOME UNDER MIGHTY
JOE BIDEN.
JOE SHOULD INVENT A SLOGAN FOR
THIS.
HOW ABOUT "MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN," IT HAS A NICE RING TO
IT.
THIS IS GOING TO BE, IF IT
HAPPENS AND JOE ENDS UP BEING
INAUGURATED IT’S GOING TO BE
TRUMP TWO WITHOUT THE TWEETS.
>> Jesse: I LIKE IT, HE’S GOOD
AT STEALING THINGS, SLOGANS,
ELECTIONS, I’M JUST KIDDING,
JUAN.
>> Juan: THANK YOU.
>> Jesse: HE ALSO PLAGIARIZED
HIS "BUILD BACK BETTER," HE TOOK
THAT FROM THE UNITED NATIONS.
I’M GOING TO BE HONEST, IF HE
STEALS THIS I’M GOOD WITH IT AND
I AM GOING TO TREAT JOE LIKE I
TREATED TRUMP.
FAIR AND BALANCED.
WHEN HE DOES SOMETHING GOOD FOR
THE COUNTRY I’M GOING TO APPLAUD
HIM.
WHEN HE DOES SOMETHING
DETRIMENTAL I’M GOING TO
SAVAGELY ATTACK HIM AND PEOPLE
WILL MARVEL ABOUT HOW FAIR I
COVER JOE BIDEN AND IF THEY CALL
ME A HYPOCRITE IF I DID
SOMETHING WITH TRUMP I DIDN’T DO
WITH BIDEN I WILL JUST WITH THE
WAY MY WAY OUT OF IT WITH SOME
REASONABLE EXPLANATION.
BUT IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, THE MADE
IN AMERICA THINK HE’S GOT ON HIS
WEB SITE SOUNDS EXACTLY LIKE
TRUMP’S PLAN, IT SOUNDS GREAT,
REINVENT MANUFACTURING AND NOT
DO THESE NEW LOPSIDED TRADE
DEALS AND THEY ARE GOING TO BUY
AMERICA FIRST, ALL THAT STUFF SO
LET’S SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Greg: WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO
DO IF HE DOES SOMETHING THAT
TRUMP DID?
ARE YOU GOING TO SAY THAT’S
TERRIBLE ARE YOU GOING TO
SUDDENLY LIKE IT?
>> Juan: THAT’S WHAT I WAS
GOING TO MAKE JESSE’S POINT,
THAT IF YOU GUYS ARE REALLY
SAYING OH, THIS IS MINUTE, YOU
LIKE WHAT TRUMP WAS DOING SO
MAYBE YOU SHOULD LIKE WHAT BIDEN
IS DOING.
IN FACT I THOUGHT YOU CONFUSE
THINGS, CLEARLY WHAT YOU HEARD
FROM BIDEN WAS BIDEN TALKING
ABOUT MILITARY ALLIANCES, OUR
INVOLVEMENT IN CLIMATE DEALS,
ALL OF THAT.
CLEARLY TRUMP CLOSED BACK AND
LEFT THE REST OF THE WORLD, OUR
ALLIES LEFT THEM.
LOOK, MY POINT IS, BIDEN WON THE
ELECTION, TRUMP LOST, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE REJECTED TRUMP
AND THAT’S THE BOTTOM LINE HERE
AND IF YOU REALLY WANT TO THINK
ABOUT IT I WOULD SAY THAT, YOU
KNOW, IF YOU REALLY THINK ABOUT
AMERICA FIRST I THINK IT WAS
TRUMP WHO DIDN’T FOLLOW THROUGH
BECAUSE WE SAW BILLIONS IN
CONTRACTS GO OVERSEAS DURING THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
>> Jesse: WE SAW A LOT OF
MANUFACTURING JOBS COME BACK.
>> Sandra: WE BECAME A NET OIL
EXPORTER UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IN ONE OF THE
FIRST THINGS HE SAYS HE’S GOING
TO ADDRESS WHEN HE RATTLES OFF
THIS "NEW YORK TIMES" INTERVIEW,
I WAS GOING TO REFUTE
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S POLICIES AS
ENERGIES AND MAYBE THAT’S AN
AREA WHERE HE’S GOING TO MAKE
SOME UNWANTED CHANGES, WHEN YOU
SAW THE AMERICAN WORKER AND
AMERICAN CONSUMER GREATLY
BENEFIT FROM THAT ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
>> Juan: I THINK WHAT YOU HAVE
TO FACTOR IN HERE IS THE
ENVIRONMENT AND I THINK LOTS OF
PEOPLE ARE AND IN FACT ALSO --
>> Dagen: OUR EMISSIONS PER
CAPITA FOR THIS COUNTRY ARE THE
LOWEST THEY’VE BEEN SINCE 1950,
JUST BROADLY SPEAKING THEY ARE
THE LOWEST THEY’VE BEEN SINCE
THE EARLY ’90s.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU DON’T PUT
AMERICA FIRST?
WHEN YOU REJOIN THE PARIS ACCORD
WHICH PUTS US, HURTS AMERICA AND
THE UNITED STATES AND ACTUALLY
LET’S CHINA, THE BIGGEST CO2
EMITTER KICKED TEN YEARS DOWN
THE ROAD BEFORE THEY HAVE TO DO
ANYTHING.
YOU KNOW IT DOESN’T PUT AMERICA
FIRST?
RAISING CORPORATE TAXES BECAUSE
IF YOU RAISE CORPORATE TAXES IN
THIS COUNTRY WHICH JOE BIDEN
PROMISED TO DO ABOUT WHERE THE
TAXES ARE IN CHINA?
IT ENCOURAGES THOSE CORPORATIONS
TO MOVE THOSE JOBS OVERSEAS.
OR BUILD FACTORIES OVERSEAS
BECAUSE THERE’S A LOWER TAX RATE
THERE.
THEY CAN MOVE THEIR HEADQUARTERS
OVER THERE AND YOU KNOW YOU
REALLY SCREW RURAL AMERICANS WHO
JOE BIDEN WAS TALKING ABOUT?
RAISE THEIR GASOLINE PRICES,
RAISE THEIR ELECTRICITY PRICES
AND TAKE AWAY THEIR JOBS IN THE
ENERGY SECTOR.
I JUST WANT JOE BIDEN TO SAY
"CHINA VIRUS."
IF HE’S GOING TO BORROW YOU KNOW
WHAT FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP, SAY
"CHINA PLAGUE" BECAUSE THAT’S
WHY 271,000 AMERICANS ARE DEAD
AND WHY A MILLION AND A HALF
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD ARE DEAD
BECAUSE THAT VIRUS CAME FROM
CHINA AND THEY LIED ABOUT IT AND
UNLEASHED A PANDEMIC ON THE
WORLD AND HE’S BEEN BLAMING
TRUMP.
SHAME ON HIM.
>> Greg: I HATE IT WHEN SHE
DOESN’T ARRIVE GEARED UP FOR THE